restaurant owner he is fighting back
against draconian lockdown measures with
this exchange with california regulators
now going viral as he fights for
the survival of his employees and his
business watch this
i followed the rules i continue to
follow the rules and you guys still
time after time are giving me citations
tell me i have to close my business what
about my employees
my tables are inside just because the
health department
has the whole process to go through that
takes however long that takes
i have to close my business for that
time are you gonna pay my rent
joining us now with an exclusive
interview of the restaurant owner in
this now viral
video anton van hoppen anton first of
all i'm sorry going through it tell us
how this all happened
so hi sean um what happened was on
friday evening
i spoke to the health department that
afternoon and i said hey listen i'm
going to put my tables outside as
a protest but i'm still going to serve
everything to go i'm not going to serve
any of my customers outside it's their
own prerogative whatever they do is what
they do it's i
it's not i'm not in a position to tell
people what to do
and he was okay with that because i'm
allowed to protest and
instead of sticking by his word uh he
sent or two health inspectors came that
evening
and they're like listen you need to shut
down and close down this uh this
restaurant here's your closure notice
so i said listen if i tip these tables
inside right now can we just skip this
whole process
and uh i'm following the rules i'm
abiding by your rules can we just
call it quits and give me a warning and
i can go on about my business they said
nope sorry here's your closure notice
you got it closed and i said well
you guys aren't open until monday so i
have to sit saturday and sunday with my
restaurant clothes i'm like that's
not possible i have rent to pay my
employees to pay so i ended up just
staying open saturday sunday
um that same uh health supervisor called
me on monday morning and
we had a conversation which i actually
recorded and i said listen you didn't
stick to your word last time
um and he said no well i'll stick to my
word this time if you send me an email
and you tell me that you're going to
comply with our rules and regulations
which i told him i had been over the
weekend already
um he said that he would lift the
closure uh the closure off of my
restaurant
so i said all right just make sure i'm
recording you right now make sure that
you stick to your word he said i will
stick to my word
so uh two hours later i got an email
from him saying you know what actually
we found out that your restaurant was
open on saturday sunday and monday
so i'm taking that back and your
restaurant needs to needs to close
immediately
um right when that uh was all hot sorry
go ahead
no no keep going i want to hear your
story oh okay so
yeah so right right when all of that was
happening a guy named jorge ventura
who's who has his his twitter page uh
was interviewing me at the same time i
was that frustrated
and just as we were ending the interview
together to another two health
inspectors walked into the restaurant
and that's the video that went viral
basically i went in and i started
talking to them and they were like you
need to close
your restaurant i said why i'm complying
it's not like i have tables outside
i'm not breaking the rules i'm complying
now i'm like why do you guys keep poking
at me
i've already complied to what you guys
want it's almost like i have my hands
tied
if i put tables outside i'm gonna get a
citation and i need to close
i put my tables inside same thing it's
like why can't you just leave me alone
and let me go about my business i i was
able to protest my two or three hours
which you guys agreed upon so let me be
now i don't i don't i don't
and anyway it went viral from there so
that's that's
that's the story and that's what
happened they didn't keep their word
yeah and then you have your governor
sitting like this close to the next
person
you know eating dinner great visual i
wish you and your business the best i
wish the best for your employees
people need to hear how hard this is on
people like yourself to put it
on the line for for your customers
unbelievable